[Musique]
mais les vous de vos affaires avec
adrian st-arnaud va répondre à une
question d'un thé spectateurs ce soir
mario robillard de bromont qui pose la
question suivante pour un besoin
ponctuel de fonds pour un court délai
puis-je puiser dans montréal ils
remettent la somme dans la même année
fiscale sans payer d'impôts ou de
pénalités grande question parce qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes qui se la pose
malheureusement pour monsieur bien la
réponse est non parce que lorsqu'on fait
le retrait d'un réel il ya une position
de revenu à la source en fait et il ya
seulement deux régimes qui permet de
retirer des sommes derrière sans payer
d'impôts le rap évidemment régime
d'accès à la propriété assez connue pour
ceux qui achètent une première maison on
peut retirer 35 mille dollars et on a
quinze ans pour rembourser son prêt pas
d'impôts lorsqu'on retire dans le fond
reér de cette manière l'autre régime
c'est pour le retour aux études
en fait où il est pour les siennes ou
celle de son conjoint par exemple on
peut retirer jusqu'à 10000 $ par année
vingt mille dollars au maximum dans une
vie on est dix ans pour rembourser mais
il faut se rappeler qu'à chaque fois
qu'on retire de l'argent dans un reér et
qu'on veut le remettre dans cet outil là
on utilise les droits de cotisation le
volet s'entendre là-dessus chantal matos
de gestion optimum un des désavantages
qui va utiliser sur et ça marche de
reillanne utilisé pour rien en fait
parce qu'il va avoir
il va l'avoir utilisé deux fois exemple
fait un meurtrier de 5000 $ ord en
céréales une cotisation qui avait déjà
fait auparavant
et là il va re quotidien autres 5000
dong europe baptisé 10000 en fait pour
prépare pour se prévaloir d'un retour
des fonds sur une cotisation de 5
minutes
donc c'est comme une perf à quelque part
de retourner aux éventuels dans une
manif tueur alors dans quoi on peut
puiser si on va avoir des liquidités
bon évidemment il ya le celi mais c'est
le même mécanisme que le reér si vous
voulez rembourser de l'argent dans votre
celi vous d'utiliser de nouveaux droits
de cotisation si vous avez des sommes
qui sont pas dans les régimes
enregistrés des obligations par exemple
si vous essayez de les vendre
aujourd'hui vous priverez pas d'un gros
rendement pour la bourse c'est peut-être
mieux de consulter son conseiller
financier le parce que c'est très
volatile mégane solution facile selon
chantal matos des emprunts on l écoute
de nouveau la meilleure
ce serait d'aller avec une marge de
crédit ou une carte de crédit à faible
le taux à ce moment là c'est beaucoup
plus simple lui va avoir un peu
d'intérêt à payer mais ça va être minime
surtout si c'est pour un court laps de
temps un mois deux mois ça sera pas
grand chose ça va être beaucoup moins
compliqué je suis à mon avis c'est la
meilleure solution et c'est important de
mentionner vous en prenez l'exemple de
5000 $ si vous utilisez une marge de
crédit à 11 % par exemple ça vous donne
des frais de 43 dollars par mois c'est
pas énorme et 11 pour ça c'est
certainement beaucoup moins que le taux
d'imposition de monsieur biya
voilà merci andré alie